por segunda vez en el mes de mayo los
seguidores del presidente yair bolsonaro
salen a la calle para mostrar su apoyo
al presidente según los organizadores
hoy va a haber 10 mil motos recorriendo
todo río de janeiro hasta el monumento
dedicado a los soldados veteranos ese me
lo toma pandini a quien ya ha matado a
450 mil personas y donde en teoría no se
puede aglomerar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
él es nuestro presidente tengo un gran
orgullo de haber votado a este
presidente vino para quedarse
[Música]
hoy es el primer encuentro de
motociclistas de río de janeiro es el
acto de motociclistas más grande de la
historia de brasil lo que está pasando
aquí es que el pueblo está mostrando
cuánto apoyo al presidente bolso nada
[Música]
hemos venido para pedir el voto impreso
el voto auditable porque ha habido
muchos fraudes en las urnas y a pesar de
tantos fraudes comprobados en 2018
conseguimos elegir nuestro presidente
nuestra urna todavía desde la primera
generación puede seguir siendo digital
pero tiene que avanzar uruguaya tiene
unas electrónicas de tercera generación
y brasil está atrasado y brasil está
atrasado en el otro lado tiene el 24 por
ciento de popularidad según la empresa
de sondeos acapol ya es decir 6 por
ciento menos que en el mes de marzo
además del 45% de la población valora su
gobierno como malo o pésimo esta
manifestación multitudinaria puede ser
interpretada como una reacción de
bolsonaro para mostrar realmente cuál es
su apoyo entre la población